MALE SPEAKER: We are thrilled
to host Sean Gerrity, who
is the president of the American
Prairie Reserve and a National
Geographic Explorer.
And the aim of the
American Prairie Reserve
is to return to the golden era
of large scale conservation
in the United States.
They aim to create
a wildlife preserve
in the prairies of Montana,
four times bigger than Yosemite,
in a size that will eventually
rival that of the Serengeti
in Africa.
And so in order to accomplish
that, there's the land deals,
there's the acquisitions,
the plans within the park.
But as Sean will say in his
speech today, the questions
and the issues that it
raises are far wider,
looking at migration patterns
with birds, with animals.
It's really a program of
nationwide importance.
And so he will go
through and talk
about what the
foundation is up to
and show some of the
latest work and some images
from the reserve.
And we'll have time for
some questions at the end.
So please join me in
welcoming Sean to Google.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SEAN GERRITY: Thank you
everybody very much.
I appreciate it.
And thanks for taking
the time to come.
I know what a day at Google
must be like-- really busy.
So I appreciate you coming out.
I think what I'll do is to get
everybody kind on the same page
is start with a very
short video, just
of a few minutes,
that was developed
by National Geographic.
I'll then go into more
detail about the project.
And as Cliff said, we'll
take some questions for you.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[BUFFALO BELLOWING]
-The American Prairie Reserve is
the largest scale conservation
project underway now
in North America, one
of the biggest in the world.
-The American Prairie
Reserve Project
is preserving one of
the fastest disappearing
pieces in the American West.
[WOLF YIPPING]
-I think one of the things
I'm most excited about
is it's not too.
-When Lewis and Clark
came through here a couple
of hundred years
ago, about the time
they got to the
Montana border is
where they saw the
wildlife really
begin to increase in abundance.
Modern day conservation
biology has
said we've got to
create vast reserves,
if we want to bring back
all the wildlife in some
of these areas.
And that's why when we created
the plans for the American
Prairie Reserve we
decided to go large.
-Our ultimate dream is to
have a three million to three
and a half million acre
fully functioning ecosystem,
where all the animals that
were there 100 years ago, 150
years ago, have an opportunity
to interact with each other
again and have a major role
and impact on the landscape.
-We're beginning to put
things back on that landscape.
And we're really excited
to think about the day when
it's all back in balance
the way it was for thousands
and thousands of years.
-We have reintroduced bison, we
currently have about 250 bison.
Clearly, we'll have the capacity
to have the largest bison
herd in the country.
-This is about the
land and the wildlife.
But it's also about people.
We're very interested
in making this area
accessible to the public.
-It has a lot of potential
for its scenic value,
for its birding.
-There is a lot of promise
for local communities.
There's a tourism
aspect, just like you'd
find in Africa, other
parts of North America,
South America, when you build
a reserve of this scale.
-If somebody had
said, would you have
liked to have been a founder, a
co-founder of Yellowstone Park,
how could you not want
to be on that team?
-It's an opportunity to be
involved in creating something
where you can see the tangible
results of your efforts
in your lifetime and have an
altruistic sense of accomplish.
-The American Prairie Reserve
is critical to the existence
of future generations.
It feeds everything
that it is to be human.
-This is the time to seize
it and secure it forever,
so it can be enjoyed for
hundreds and hundreds of years.
[END PLAYBACK]
SEAN GERRITY: OK, so as you
may have read in my background,
I grew up in Montana.
I work there now.
But I spent about 20
years in this valley,
working in a for profit.
I started a company
back in 1984.
It's still going 33 years later.
We had an idea at the
time, and it seems
to have stuck pretty well.
And I learned a lot
working here for 20 years.
I know what the Valley
is like, I know the pace.
I know what it takes
to be successful here.
Our business at
the time, I don't
know how much it's changed.
But at the time,
people in the Valley
were struggling
and going as fast
as they could to
hire the smartest
people they could
beg, borrow, or steal
to assemble their companies.
And it was kind of
like hiring studio
musicians, who were exceedingly
good as individuals.
But you put them all
together, and it was really
difficult sometimes
to create a band
and get those albums out the
door on a quarterly basis,
before you missed the window.
We had an idea on how
we could get teams up
and running, focused
on a common vision,
faster than they would
normally otherwise do,
particularly the
special individuals
that were coming to
the Valley at the time.
I did that for about 20
years, and it sent me
all over the world, working with
lots of different industries,
not just high tech.
I was based here.
We built our company
up to about 40 people.
And again, it's still going.
So now what I've done
is parlay the skills
and the ideas I got working
with so many different kinds
of folks in so many
different kinds of industry
to something I
really care about,
which also takes aligning a lot
of people onto a common vision,
over a very long period of
time, not just for six or nine
months.
So let me tell you a bit
more about the project
than the movie went into,
and what we're up to.
As it said there, we're working
on a very, very large scale--
I'll tell you about that--
to put back everything that
used to be there, not
just little museum
pieces but all the
wildlife, including
the top trophic predators.
Quite an ambitious effort.
Some people said this
era is long gone,
that you're just not able to
do this kind of thing anymore.
We haven't done anything for
the last 60 years like it.
We think it can be.
And we're making some
really good progress.
So when we talk about
big, how big are we going?
It's a lot of square miles,
comes up to over three million
acres, the size of this
thing when it's done.
About the side of the
state of Connecticut,
for everybody who's
moved from back east.
But maybe the best image is
the idea of the Serengeti,
from a sheer square mile
standpoint and also the numbers
and variety of wildlife
on the landscape.
Since we're in
California, if you
were to take a picture
of the eventual reserve,
the size of it, if you put
one edge on the Golden Gate,
the other edge would go
far into the Sierra Nevada.
Imagine one very lonely
paved road bisecting it,
the rest of it all wildlife.
No towns, just animals.
Scientists tell us there
are only four places
left on earth to do a project
of this scale on the grasslands.
Only four places left.
And as we sit here today,
they're all shrinking.
They're being plowed
up at the edges
to grow food for
our growing species.
We're working up there in
the Northern Great Plains,
for a lot of reasons, we
think one of the best spots,
if not the best
spot in the world
to do this kind of
project at this size.
So if you zoom into the
Northern Great Plains,
you'll see that it touches about
five states and two provinces
of Canada.
On that little blue
spot is the best spot,
for a variety of
reasons, and it just
happens to be up in Northeastern
Montana is where it is.
So a couple of reasons
why it's the best.
Of all that big green
splotch there, it
has not yet been farmed,
it hasn't been plowed up.
That's really key to do
something at this scale.
A second reason is there's
a wildlife history that
existed there, I'll
tell you about,
that didn't exist anywhere
else in the Great Plains
to this extent.
You don't have to buy it all.
You only have to buy a small
amount and use that as glue,
to pull together
existing public lands
to make the whole model work.
And very unusual, unlike the
place where we're sitting here,
people are moving out from
rural areas to the cities.
And that's actually going
on since about World War I,
that steady decline
of population
gives us a lot of opportunity
to buy and assemble
a great deal of land.
Now when you go over that
green area of the Great Plains,
most of it looks like this.
It's very fragmented,
fenced, under cultivation,
growing food for us, as I said.
But there's one special,
very spectacular spot
in that place where
I've been showing you,
where it's not yet turned over,
a blank canvas, if you will.
If we can assemble it it in time
to put this whole thing back
together, we believe we do it,
and we can save it forever.
The stories of wildlife have
been passed down actually
for thousands of years.
People have been living on
this area, this landscape,
since about 11,000 years ago,
when the last ice age receded.
The stories of the wildlife
passed down through modern day
Native Americans who
have been there recently,
in the last 600 or
700 years-- Crows,
Gros Ventre, Assiniboine,
Flatheads, Pend d'Oreilles.
And people then started
writing it down,
actually the stories, with
fur trappers from Hudson Bay
Company in the late
1700s, of course
Lewis and Clark,
in the early 1800s,
told stories of being out
here, and what an incredibly
beautiful place it was.
But also, the
wildlife experience,
it was like nowhere
else in North America.
People came also from Europe.
Later on, as these stories
spread around the world,
people like Karl Bodmer
who came from Germany
and did 50 images in this area.
And they said at the
time, in the 1830s,
the Americans ought to save
this, before it's all gone.
It's extraordinary.
We didn't save it.
Quite the opposite, with
Manifest Destiny people
came out, brought
livestock, put up fences.
And the wildlife went away.
And I mean, entirely went away.
In that Connecticut Serengeti
size place I'm talking about,
every single bison, cougar,
grizzly bear, wolf, and more
were completely eradicated.
Not one left in that area.
That's a tough start
for a project like this.
But while that
was happening, how
you'll probably remember in the
1870s, another idea was waxing.
And that was some people
call it America's best idea,
and that's of our
national parks.
It was a golden era.
It lasted until
about 1950, when we
did our last one, Grand Teton.
But during that amount
of time, we did Yosemite,
we did Glacier, the Grand
Canyon, the Everglades.
It was incredible what happened.
But we stopped.
And we haven't done
one for 60 years.
And ironically, we
missed the grasslands
during that golden age.
And the grasslands,
because they're
low elevation and
incredible forage,
they have a carrying
capacity for wildlife,
a biological carrying
that exceeds all these
other parks combined.
So our idea is to
restart that era.
And right up there in
that dot I've showed you,
build the biggest
one that's ever
been done, with an innovative
public private partnership
this time around.
A million acres bigger
than Yellowstone.
You can put all that wildlife
back and save it forever.
I was in business
here for 20 years.
I know what you guys have
to deal with each day.
Focus, setting goals,
staying focused,
watching the scope creep.
I know that.
So we have three areas.
And we always break things
into three, as you know.
One is about assembling
the landscape.
I'll tell you more about that.
The next is when you have
the landscape together,
converting it or remodeling
it from livestock value
to biodiversity value.
And lastly, how do we make sure
human beings, the people who
live in the area and
folks who are beginning
to visit from around
the world, how
do they begin to enjoy
and interact with it now?
Not waiting until
we're completely done.
So going through
these three just
quickly, understanding
the landscape ownership
is key to understanding
the model, and why we can
move so fast and so affordably.
That oval, there's that
Connecticut, Serengeti size
piece of property
there, it's big.
The white pieces up there, the
white pieces are private land.
And our model has us buying
500,000 acres of private bits
and gluing together all
the other colors, which
are different kinds
of public lands--
Bureau of Land Management,
Fish and Wildlife Service, et
cetera.
The idea is to put
it all together
and eventually create a
seamlessly managed reserve,
after you've taken
down, frankly,
thousands of miles
of barbed wire fence.
The blue pieces here show
your our progress to date.
We started from scratch, not
knowing how to raise money.
We've raised nearly
$80 million so far.
We've spent it really
quickly on land.
This shows you about 16 to 17
property acquisitions to date.
Our property acquisitions
tend to be big.
They're about the
size of Palo Alto.
Some are about the size
of Santa Clara County.
That's the size of the ranches
we're putting together.
Not easy, they're very complex.
Eventually, we have 310,000
acres right now, we're
adding about 30,000 acres
a year to our model.
When it's finished, the reserve
will look something like that.
You can pull those boundaries
easily where you like.
But that's the square
kilometers or square miles.
Of course it won't
be that exact shape.
But that's the idea.
Seamlessly managed reserve.
If you're an individual
or a herd of elk
you can walk across that.
And you won't know
who owns what,
because the fences are
down, as are the "keep out"
signs that are existing today.
People ask us, how can
you in this day and age
build something this big?
It must be incredibly
expensive to do this.
It used to be done
by government fiat.
So we say, well
take a look at some
of the things we're building
today at universities,
hospitals, museums.
Next year, we're going to
start three new NFL football
stadiums.
They come in a little
over $1 billion apiece.
This project, the
biggest reserve ever done
in this country, all the
endowment, all the management
costs and all the
land purchase costs
are going to come in at just a
little bit over half the price
of one new football stadium.
We think it's very
affordable, very doable.
The second piece
here is the idea
of biodiversity restoration.
And this is where
some of the things
I learned in Silicon
Valley come into play.
It's how do you look at
something that's that big, just
extraordinarily big, and get a
handle on what you just bought,
and how you're going to
do the remodeling project?
You need to go
out and understand
what it's like in
all kinds of seasons,
in all kinds of
different topography.
So in fact, using
Google technology,
we're using a combination
of extremely low tech
with a very high tech
approach to doing this.
It was daunting
in the beginning.
We found out about
a group called
Adventurers and Scientists
for Conservation.
A brilliant young
man started the idea.
And he brings what's
called adventure scientists
from all around the world.
And they walk on our reserve.
Here, you see them in the middle
of winter, walking at about 25
below zero.
They also walk in
August, at 105 above.
We give them the
information and teach them
how to look for
the things that are
important to us for our
restoration and management
processes.
They go out every day,
they're out there today.
They walk anywhere from 5 to 15
miles a day, five days a week
to collect the
information for us,
in all kinds of temperatures.
Just in the first three
years of the project,
they'll have done
one circumnavigation
of the entire earth, just
in this project area.
This is six people.
We switch them out
as they get tired.
We get new ones, fresh horses.
Here's an example.
Today, they're walking in what's
called the Sun Prairie unit.
It's about 40 square
miles, about the size
of greater San Jose area.
So this morning what
they would have done
is gotten together with
their Google tablets.
They key in their GPS
units and their transects.
When they go out,
they start to see
information, the kind of things
that we have them looking for.
They make information, they take
videos, they take photographs,
they write, et cetera.
I live 300 miles away from the
reserve in Bozeman, Montana.
And I can at night then
take a look at these pins,
you're familiar with all this,
and see what happened that day.
I can see they saw some
pronghorn antelope.
That means they came back
from Canada in the summer.
Now they're back on the
reserve, that's cool.
See what they were doing,
where they were going,
all of that, when they
were having their babies.
They might have downloaded one
of 50 different camera traps
spread across 50 square miles.
And this may look
boring, an elk eating.
But it's interesting to us.
It's 2:30 in the morning,
it's 15 degrees below zero.
And even more interesting,
because we wanted this test,
that fence he's standing
by has one hot wire
running 7,000 volts through it.
It keeps our bison in, but
it's permeable, like Gore-Tex,
to other wildlife.
In about five more
minutes here, he
turns and jumps right
through the fence and scrapes
on that hot wire, and
it doesn't bother him.
That's what we're looking for.
So these folks, who are
doing very low tech stuff,
very thoughtful, slow walking
people looking at things,
using high tech they load
us the information using
Google technology.
To us, we can make good
management decisions.
Another challenge,
I'm sure you recognize
this with the kind of
projects you're doing.
When you go for
something this big,
it's hard to do it by yourself.
You need collaborators.
Here's an example of some
of our collaborators.
But they come from their own
cultures and their own world.
They see things differently,
speak a different language.
How do you pull
them all together
to work on this one project?
I want them to look through the
same lens at this landscape,
all through the same
lens, and figure out
how to work together.
So we had to come up
with our own language.
We called it the Freese Scale.
As it's very simple thing.
Mostly, we've taken
what you'd define
as a fully functioning
grassland ecosystem,
break it into 10 easily
discussable topic areas,
and say we want to
move up on the scale.
We want to move into
the blue, as it were.
That's what success
looks like, it's
a high score on this
particular scale.
So for instance, number
eight is predators.
The people who are
walking out there today,
just last week they saw
their very first live cougar.
Even cougar specialists
in their entire lifetime
don't get to see live
cougars oftentimes.
They saw one last week.
So they would mark it two.
At least we have a cougar.
But you don't get
any higher than that.
Because we have no wolves
and no grizzly bears, yet.
So on big predators, you
would get a low score.
So our groups of
collaborators go out
into these Palo Alto or
Mountain View sized landscapes,
walk, and work together, using
the same language to give
the thing a baseline score.
You can add this up.
Obviously, you've got
a total of 70 possible.
And this particular
piece of ground got a 28.
It also allows them to then talk
about year by year management
plans for moving the needle.
And we all look at it
through the same way.
And we have the same
success criteria.
So this is really key for us.
Some of the things
we're doing out there,
we're doing all kinds of stuff.
For instance, you saw one
of those things on fire.
We want to incorporate natural
fire back into the landscape.
We have to force it a bit.
But we burn up lots
and lots of prairie,
like thousands of
acres at a time.
That rejuvenates both the
soil, but it brings back
the variety in the plant world.
It's gotten too
homogeneous out there.
Once we get that
variety going again,
we start to see
success in grasslands.
Birds coming back
not just in numbers.
We want abundance, but
we also want diversity.
So when the diversity and
the abundance go up together,
now we're starting to win.
We take down lots
and lots of fence,
so animals that can run
like pronghorn, like 65
miles per hour, fastest land
mammal in North America,
they don't do so well
when they hit fences.
Lots of fences coming
down, hundreds of miles,
allowing pronghorn, bighorn
sheep, other prairie animals
like elk to move freely
across a landscape again.
We're importing some animals.
Swift fox are coming soon.
We started with bison, who
were gone for 100 years.
We started with 16.
With babies this year, we'll
be up over 600, on our way
to 10,000, which will be by far
the largest herd on the planet.
And making room for
top trophic predators.
For us, that's grizzly bears,
wolves, and mountain lions.
Mountain lions just got
back, about 15 years ago,
after an 80-year absence.
Wolves and bears are
getting closer all the time.
Last thing, and that's
the human element,
very important to us
in two distinct ways.
The visitors, for sure.
But what's really important
in big scale conservation
around the world
is the people who
live in the periphery of
something like this vision.
And you have to understand
the context you're working in.
It could be fishermen,
it could be loggers.
In our case, it's
cattle ranchers.
More than 200 of them, raising
more than half a million head
of cattle.
They took a long time getting
rid of all those bison, wolves,
and bears.
Why would they want them back?
We have to figure out--
they have to figure out,
what's in this for us.
They don't start off
excited, let me tell you.
So we have to figure
out what can we do,
if you think about it,
to soften those borders
around this big,
big, huge reserve.
I mean, this is really big.
How do we figure
out a way that they
can be winners in this thing?
We have a number of ideas.
The first one out
of the gate that
tries to address what they want
to be, which is being a cattle
rancher, we started the only
wildlife-friendly beef company
in the US.
It's called Wild Sky Beef.
We're now selling thousands
of pounds of beef a week.
You can get it in California,
New York, et cetera.
Here's the idea.
We go to them and say,
if you'll raise your beef
to our protocols,
which is this Freese
Scale, the exact same thing
we use to judge ourselves
in the core reserve,
you're on the periphery.
If you'll raise your
beef to these protocols,
it will be like Delta, with the
silver and gold and platinum
levels.
As you start to move up,
you get $0.05 per pound
live weight premium,
or $0.06, or $0.07,
depending on how far
you get up that scale.
Now the neat thing is
now cattle ranchers,
who were not too
excited about this,
are using the exact same scale.
As you know in business, our
motivations can be different.
But we're aligned to the
same desired end result,
and that's beautiful.
So Wild Sky is our first
idea out the door with this,
and it's working pretty well.
We have others to try
to soften those borders,
this is really key.
I talked about biological
carrying capacity
of grasslands.
Out here, there's probably a
biological carrying capacity
for about 600 grizzly bears.
But what is the social
carrying capacity,
that's in the tolerance of
people, for all those bears?
It might be about
five right now.
That might be pushing it.
But we're going to get there.
Most of our work is not science.
It's actually sociology
and psychology.
How do you increase the
social carrying capacity
for wildlife around the world?
Marine ecosystems are
the thing we're building.
Visitors from around the
world are important to us.
I've been to numerous
parks in Africa.
And it's often segmented,
based on what you can afford.
We want this to
be for the public.
be for everybody.
We've opened campgrounds,
just like you'd
find at the base El Cap
and Camp Four. $10 a night,
people are enjoying that.
We're building more.
We want to make sure
people are educated
and walk away enlightened
and excited and inspired.
So there's lots of signage
going up, helping people
to understand species
by species how
things fit, even like prairie
dogs, in the ecological niche.
Why they're so keystone,
why they're important.
Some people want to
come out and camp,
but they have a different
idea what camping looks like.
And they want to be out and have
the adventures during the day,
happy to get dirty
being out in the wind,
traveling with our guides.
But they want to
be able to say, I
was in a tent, which
these are-- for sure,
they are canvas
tents, technically.
But so they can go home
and brag about that.
But they like air
conditioning and heat
and really nice thread
count sheets and showers
and this sort of thing.
This is Kestrel Camp.
They also get tired of ramen.
So we don't give them ramen.
We give them other things
when they're there.
And we have a very
nice wine list.
But they're out
there during the day
having these amazing,
big adventures.
But then they come
back, and they're
able to spend time with
our naturalist guides,
spend time with
the other guests,
and get ready after a good
night's sleep in these tents,
go at it again the next day.
There are lots of
other ways we're
getting people-- we're
working on layering in ways
to experience the prairie.
I, again, 20 years
in Silicon Valley.
I get the speed around here.
Slowing people
down is important.
What you're seeing
here is a transect
I'm doing with some
folks in September.
We'll walk 250 miles,
from side to side,
across the reserve
in 14 or 15 days.
Very slow circuitous
route- artists, writers,
some journalists, naturalists,
guides and others.
And just have what we call a
land snorkeling roving salon,
basically.
And yeah, it's 250 miles.
Not so bad though, when
you can take time to stop
and have wonderful discussions.
If any of you have
kayaked or boated
down the Grand Canyon
for three weeks,
it's a similar kind of thing.
Just cut off the outside
world for a while.
Kids are just fantastic
to bring out here.
And what I really love is when
they shut off their devices.
I know it's important they
use their Google products.
[LAUGHTER]
But for a little
bit, we ask them--
they don't work
out there anyway.
So we asked them to just
put down their devices,
teach them about this
naturalist stuff.
And they just
absolutely come alive.
They are really inspired
by what they're seeing.
And we try to show them things
at the micro level, you know,
nematodes in the dirt.
At the medium level, there are
some 2,000-pound bison walking
by, from a few yards away.
But we also try to get them to
look at the big level as well.
How this huge landscape, in
this big park that's being
built for them, is important.
But it's connected to
something even bigger.
And so we tell about
these pronghorn.
Again, these are
very fast animals.
But we tell them this is
only part of their home.
Because every year, they
actually leave not only
Montana, but they leave
the United States.
They walk 250 miles
north into Canada.
That is their migration, the
longest pronghorn migration
in the country.
They come back to Montana
in the wintertime.
Long-billed curlews,
as Californians,
you will see walking up
and down the beach here
in California, but
only in the winter.
Because in the summer,
they're in Montana.
Same bird.
They come up and they nest on
the American Prairie Reserve.
And then they go to the Gulf.
They come to California
in the wintertime to rest.
And they turn around,
and they come back
and do that each year.
It's a big migration.
We tell the kids, we show them
a Swainson's hawk and we say,
guess what.
These guys are really amazing.
Swainson's, far bigger than
a curlew, they nest as well,
have their babies on American
Prairie Reserve, and then
this migration, all the
way to southern Argentina.
14,000 miles round trip.
They need to have solid anchors
and solid homes on both ends
that are not getting plowed up.
Because they lose that
habitat, and then we lose
the Swainson's.
So we're trying to
help them understand
the vastness of this
thing that we are building
for them and their grandkids.
But also how it's interconnected
to so many other things,
by these unthought of
species that travel so far.
We love, again, it's important
that they use their technology
products sometimes.
But we love just having
them get quiet and just kind
of contemplate all this.
And even sit and just
getting used to the sounds
of the Reserve as well.
[ANIMAL SOUNDS]
So the chance to work on
this project, really, I think
is an incredible
privilege for me.
I think our board and our
staff and our many supporters
feel the same way about it.
Maybe one of the most
satisfying things to me
is the idea of
its lasting value.
In a world where so many
things we build our impermanent
and ephemeral, this reserve,
like Yosemite and Yellowstone,
we know will be here hundreds
and hundreds of years
from today.
That's pretty cool, I think.
Personally, I like
the idea that we
might be inspiring young
people with the realization
that not everything big
and exciting and important
has been done yet.
There's still a lot of room
for them to contribute.
I want to show them that if
you can dream big and assemble
a group of talented, very
ambitious and caring people,
you can still do
incredible things.
A big part of this project
involves constantly
testing conventional wisdom.
And I learned to do that,
after 20 years in this valley.
That's for sure.
We've asked, is that golden
age of large scale conservation
really over?
What conditions might we
be able to get in place
to try to restart it again?
We've also said, how might we
increase the social carrying
capacity for wildlife in
big reserves like this
around the world?
What if we could find and make
a way for all the stakeholders
to be winners in the process?
These questions are fun.
And they have led us to a lot of
breakthroughs, like the Freese
Scale, like Wild Sky Beef.
I hope all of you
appreciate the advantages
of working in a place
like Silicon Valley
and an innovative
environment like Google.
I think you're amassing
skills by the week
that you could apply to
a range of endeavors that
could be immensely satisfying
to you and incredibly meaningful
to society.
And I hope you'll find the
time to come experience
this place, this big project.
It is, in fact,
being built for you.
So please come see
us sometime soon.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: What's the biggest
challenge that you all
face in dealing with
the existing landowners
and in expanding the park?
SEAN GERRITY: I think
probably the biggest one
is trying to understand
how big we're going to go.
And I think the main
thing, as I said,
how they can be
winners in the process.
What is in it for them.
Wild Sky Beef is a good start.
Just setting up and
being neighbors,
we have full time employees
out there, is a good start.
But the biggest challenge
is getting people
to see how we're going to use it
differently than how it's been
used for the last 100 years.
AUDIENCE: So you talked
about this already
throughout the talk.
But I guess, which
Silicon Valley lessons
are most important
for this start up?
And in what ways has it
been the most different
from Silicon Valley?
SEAN GERRITY: Well,
that's a good question.
I've never been involved
in non-profits before.
I didn't really know
what the difference was.
And I think the
interesting thing,
people are surprised
by my answer,
is I don't see any difference.
I started a company
from scratch.
I worked with a lot
of VCs over 20 years.
I know what it's
like to try to get
an enterprise off the ground.
Absolutely no
difference whatsoever,
in terms of particularly how
you set up your organization,
set quarterly objectives,
get a very clear set
of visionary goals that
are out about 18 months
and jump to those goals
and reset it again.
No difference whatsoever,
same I did in biotech,
in the movie industry, and
banking, whatever else.
I don't see any difference
with a for profit or nonprofit.
Maybe that's a surprise.
The fundraising
was a major shock.
I thought you just get
a sales force going,
get a great executive
vice president of sales.
And then everything's
great, and I don't
have to think about it anymore.
I can do what I got
involved in this for.
That didn't happen.
We have raised a lot of money.
It's more work
than I understood.
And I didn't quite get
the idea of the lack
of tangible quid pro quo.
When I had a product
to sell here,
there was an exchange
of good or service.
It takes a very special
person to give money.
We found hundreds,
actually thousands of them.
But the idea of just pure,
intrinsic value is tricky.
And so, that is a big challenge.
I think the best-- probably
the best lessons I mentioned
a couple of times here is in
the world of conservation,
I'm not going to
say non-profits,
but in the industry
of conservation,
the assumptions are
incredibly rigid, I feel.
And we come in and
say, does that really
have to be like that?
Is there another
way of doing it?
How about we start
a for profit company
that's owned by our non-profit?
So many people said, can
you even do that legally?
Absolutely you can
do that legally.
So America Prairie Reserve
owns Wild Sky Beef.
It's a for profit company
owned by a nonprofit.
Lots of things like that.
Pushing conventional
wisdom, thinking
about how you can
change hearts and minds
with the seed of an idea
and then just moving
it forward increments.
Not trying to bowl people
over with the end result.
That works here, I know.
And probably the
lesson here is things
are not as easy as it seems.
If you really knew how many
hours people actually put in
to start a company, most people
think, well that was easy.
They just lucked out with this
idea, and they all got rich.
It's not how it happens.
I never experienced that,
between '84 and 2000.
And I think the work
ethic is really important.
I do think some
non-profits, to me,
just complain about
the outside world
not getting their mission.
They would give us
more money, et cetera.
They're not going to get it.
You just have to work
really, really hard,
for a very long period of time.
This is just some of
the things I think.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned using
some of the Google technologies
to track some of the
animals and photos.
I'm curious which
ones you're using,
and how they're working for you?
SEAN GERRITY: We're
scratching the surface.
And we'd very much
like more help.
So the most initial
ones right now
are laying out the
information that we
are getting from the
folks that are walking.
Or being able to track-- we
have satellite radio collars
on some of the female bison.
They're like they're
female elephants.
If you can find the key females,
you can find the whole herd.
And so they go wander big areas.
So understanding
how to build maps.
Where have they been,
not just last night,
but over the last
three months or so.
And what are the
patterns we can see?
Why do they keep using
these particular areas?
They can go wherever they want.
So that's really interesting.
But it's probably a pretty low
level use of your technology,
actually.
But it's a big deal for us,
for management decisions.
Beginning to get-- what I
would really love help on
is getting people to understand
what it looks like out there.
My guess is when
you think prairie,
you might think about
cornfields in Kansas.
That's not the scene
that is out there.
As you-- I don't know
if I can go backwards.
As you see that, it's not
the prairie in Kansas.
That's for sure.
So the idea of even as
simple as the backpacks
that you can be carried and do
Google Street View, something
like that, to be able to take
the story out to the world.
Last year I was in Azerbaijan,
I was in the United Arab
Emirates, I was in
London and Amsterdam.
We're starting from scratch,
showing up in person.
That's a lot of work.
If we could use Google
technology and information
like Street View to help
people understand what
we have out there and bring
things to them in a new way,
that would accelerate
our project.
So we're just beginning
to think about how
we might work with Google.
We would just love it.
AUDIENCE: A couple of questions.
One is did you look at making
it a public private partnership,
getting some government
money or not?
And if you didn't, do you
think you will eventually
become self-sustainable,
where you won't need
any additional funding at all?
And the second question is how
did you come up with the land
area that you need?
Why this much land,
why not less land?
SEAN GERRITY: Yeah, let me go
backwards from the why 5,000
square miles, where
did that come from.
What that came from is
conservation biologists looking
at grasslands in Africa,
Kazakhstan, Mongolia, et
cetera, taking a
look at if you have
a fully functioning ecosystem
with enough wildlife
for genetic diversity
and all that,
how much land might they need
to fold back in on themselves
and for everything to work?
What you need in the
grasslands is bigger
than most places like forests.
Because there's natural
disasters that occur,
like an icing over.
In Montana where we are, you
can have maybe 400 or 500
square miles get
snow than melting,
we call it a chinook, and
then more snow and then more
melting.
And the ice is so thick,
except for a bison,
most everything else
can't paw through it.
They can't feed,
they'll starve to death.
They need to be able to
shift over, like 80 miles.
That's a big shift, like
going from here to Sacramento
to find food.
Because the entire Bay
Area is totally iced.
So you need big areas, so
you can have those disasters,
sometimes big fires,
which actually
a year later rejuvenate the
soil and make things better,
in the meanwhile
you're very hungry.
So the threat of
fire and ice, which
is good for the
landscape, not good when
you need to eat the next month.
You need to be
able to move about.
That's why it's so big.
A lot of animals,
frankly, it's not
because they're cantankerous.
But they don't quite get along.
A grizzly bear needs
a lot of territory,
about 100 square miles.
They don't like bumping
into each other.
And you have conflicts
when it's too tight.
So wolf packs,
grizzly bears, cougars
don't overlap in
their territory.
It doesn't work.
And big predators like
that need a lot of protein,
a lot of room, and not
conflicts with other species.
So grasslands are
some of the biggest,
about like marine
ecosystems, frankly.
Tell me your other
question, sorry.
That's how we got to
5,000 square miles.
AUDIENCE: Tell me
about government money.
SEAN GERRITY: Government
money, we would love some.
If you know any government
people with extra money,
we'll stay after.
Here's how the government
is contributing marvelously.
Frankly, I have no complaints.
Fundraising is hard, for sure.
We're using it to
buy the private land.
But the government is allowing
us, very progressively, I
think, to use 2 and 1/2 million
acres of BLM for this purpose.
And we don't have to buy it.
That saves about
$4 or $5 billion.
That's key.
They're allowing us to use
government public land,
without any kind of product like
oil and gas, timber, mining,
or cattle ranching.
They're not asking us to use
it for commercial purposes.
That's fantastic.
And we're one of the only ones
they're allowing to do that.
It's just never
been asked before.
Hey, can we use
millions and millions
of acres for absolutely nothing,
except the public's enjoyment?
So that's cool, I mean,
we don't have to buy it.
Now if there's some extra
cash to help us out,
that would be
absolutely delightful.
We just haven't
penetrated that gain yet.
Some of the bigger
organizations,
Nature Conservancy,
World Wildlife Fund,
and Wildlife Conservation
Society, are good at it.
But it took them 30 or 40
years to get good at it.
We're a little
late to that party.
AUDIENCE: Thanks so much.
I'm really excited about this.
Can you tell me about global
warming, climate change,
and how that's going to affect
the reserve over the years?
And if you're thinking
about that as a problem?
SEAN GERRITY: We're
thinking about it for sure.
We're trying to work within
our sphere of influence,
not out on our whole
spirit of concern.
It certainly is
happening, undeniably.
We can argue for days
whose fault it is.
But it is happening.
So for us, we look at how
do we protect ourselves
against the possible downsides.
The main thing is to go big,
like we just talked about.
That's why you go so big.
If it gets warmer and
drier, we need more land
to support the same
kind of wildlife.
Actually if it gets
warmer and more humid,
it's actually a plus.
We don't know which
way it's going to go.
If you had driven from here
across the United States,
you will feel dry in
California and around Davis,
dry in Nevada, dry in Montana.
And you get just a
little bit halfway
into North Dakota,
and all of the sudden,
you hit the wall of humanity.
You ever had that?
Minnesota, Wisconsin, all
of the sudden it gets humid.
With more humidity,
it gets hotter too.
You have lots more forage,
much more carrying capacity.
We don't know which way
that's going to go for us.
We're right on that line.
The only thing we can do
is go absolutely huge.
Make it bigger, don't settle.
Don't compromise just because
we got tired of fundraising.
That's the main thing.
There are, by the way, if
you go back 11,000 years,
and we didn't have the NOAA
or any weather services,
but we can do core
samples in the dry lakes.
And we can see
what kind of pollen
existed 4,000 years ago, 7,000
years ago, 9,000 years ago.
The pollen, you can
extrapolate what kind of plants
you had around you, right.
There was a period of
time a drought, a big one.
It was called the Alta Thermal.
It started 8,500 years ago and
went to about 5,000 years ago.
A 3,500 year drought,
where rainfall
was at about 13 inches, dropped
down to about seven inches
a year for 3,500 years.
And there was still
wildlife out there.
Then it slowly came
back, very slowly,
over about a period
of 800 or 900 years
and came back to about
the average we have today,
which is 13 inches a year.
But that's a heck of a drought.
I'm not worried about
drought or global warming.
I don't mean to be
cavalier, but these wildlife
are unbelievably resourceful,
in terms of the conditions they
can live in.
AUDIENCE: Follow up on
that question actually.
Perennial bunch grass
has a high capacity
for carbon sequestration.
So is there an
opportunity as you
transition these ranch systems
back to traditional ecosystems
to sell offsets or
sort of leverage
that sequestration to sort
of push this project forward?
SEAN GERRITY: We get excited
and less excited here and there,
waxing and waning our
enthusiasm, based on the carbon
markets.
It's been stumbling a bit.
So we're ready.
The land is really big,
and you're exactly right.
Eventually, this will
be seen, I think,
as a terrific carbon
sink and viable
for what you're describing.
In fact, the very first
group, from California,
has contacted us and
finally has a model
to where they can
give us what we
think is meaningful money on
a yearly basis, about $100,000
a year.
That doesn't buy
much land, but that's
about what we can get for now.
If we nail down one piece,
put a conservation easement
on it, which we're doing anyway.
And we're waiting for the
markets to catch up with us.
We're ready to go.
Know any great people,
tell them to call us.
We're on the hunt.
But you poke around
at it, and it's not
quite ready for prime time.
AUDIENCE: I have two questions.
My first question is about
the BLM and your agreement
with them.
Do they reserve the right to
come back 10, 20 years from now
and mine or pull anything that
they want to out of there,
without any consideration
of your original agreement?
And my second question
is about predators,
and how you're working
with the landowners that
are around the borders of
this area to get them to--
because the predators
are going to migrate too.
So how are they going to
welcome them into the fold?
SEAN GERRITY: With the
Bureau of Land Management,
you don't actually get a
contract or an agreement,
you get a lease.
They tend to be 10 years.
You can ask for 15 years.
Where we're working,
since it started in 1936,
there's been no precedent
for them taking things away
from people, or neighbors
competing for neighbor's
property, that kind of thing.
So it's relatively
relaxed and calm.
There are other jurisdictions
like New Mexico, Utah,
and Nevada where the BLM can
be a lot more contentious.
But it's culturally--
it's regional,
and Montana is kind
of a calm backwater,
from a BLM standpoint,
thankfully.
The other thing I learned
in Silicon Valley,
back to your original
question, about what
are some of the
important things is
when you want to get together
with some collaborators, study
very, very carefully
where they're going.
What are their values, what's
important to them in five, 10,
15 years.
We've taken a look at
their strategic plan
and the trajectory of the BLM.
They're going in the
direction of more open lands
for the public, a higher
emphasis on biodiversity,
if they don't get too much
pressure from industry.
So we are a breath of fresh air.
We are where they want to go.
So we're actually
moving them faster
to their own strategic
plan than they are.
We feel, we're trusting that
it's very unlikely they're
going to disrupt our path.
Because this is the
kind of collaboration
they want, and you usually can't
get at this kind of a scale.
So we're trusting that it's
going to last quite some time
and to race actually, to
create what I described here,
to where people cherish it so
much that they will go berserk
if the government
tries to do anything.
Like what happened with the
Arctic National Wildlife Refuge
about eight years ago.
They thought, let's just drill
there to increase our reserves.
The public didn't
put up with it.
They stopped it.
Now that may get
threatened again,
but this is in the lower 48.
People are coming to visit it.
People are falling
in love with it.
So our goal is to make it
such a rich cultural thing
and so wanted and valued
by the American public
that it would be quite
a fight to do something
in the patchy areas of BLM.
With the predators we're
doing a variety of things.
One is we're paying
them money to not
complain about predators.
Two-- that's not fair,
you just can't say
don't complain--
we're showing them
ways to deal with them
that we're bringing back
from various areas
around the world.
For instance, like in Namibia,
in the Waterberg Plateau
in northern Namibia, I
got to visit a rancher
area, very similar to this.
They don't have wolves,
but they had cheetahs.
And cheetahs kill
a lot of cattle.
So do leopards.
So they killed them left
and right, the ranchers do.
They see it as a threat.
A woman named Laurie Marker
started an organization there,
The Cheetah Conservation Fund.
And she brought in
predator controlling dogs.
There's kagans, there's
Anatolian bear dogs, even
Great Pyrenees, and others,
they all take different roles.
But say you take a couple
of dogs about this size,
like Anatolian bear dogs.
They're more awake than
this guy seems to be.
But you give the rancher
two little puppies.
And they put them, in this
case, with their goats.
They don't herd, they're
worthless for herding.
But they think the
goats are their buddies.
A leopard or a cheetah
comes in, they break away
from the goat herd and they'll
chase that cheetah down.
If they catch it,
they'll tear it apart.
So you put in
predator control dogs.
And they're $1,500 apiece.
And you give them $3,000
worth of these little puppies,
show them how to use them.
Show them how to stir
them into their cattle.
And you lessen the chances
of coyotes or other things
bothering your livestock.
The other thing we need to do
is make a landscape really big
and put wild protein
back in the landscape.
There's about 3,500 elk
out there right now.
We're shooting for
30,000 to 40,000 elk.
There was no bison until
we brought them in.
We're shooting for 10,000.
With enough bison and
elk to chase around,
the livestock are
not that interesting.
Seriously, I live
near Yellowstone.
Very, very few cows ever
get killed by wolves.
And Yellowstone is completely
surrounded by cattle ranching.
They make a lot
of noise about it,
but you don't see
a lot of dead cows.
You do see a lot of elk dying.
So, lots and lots of
protein in a landscape,
it's a distraction thing.
And make sure it's
big enough that they
can live on this landscape.
It's going to be a million acres
bigger than Yellowstone Park.
And lots of dead
things, frankly.
Grizzly bears, their
favorite thing?
A dead bison.
Nothing like a 2,000
pound dead bison
sitting there to make your
day, if you're a grizzly bear.
AUDIENCE: Are you
introducing them,
or are you just waiting
for them to arrive?
SEAN GERRITY: The latter.
We can't do that, but
they're getting close.
We know exactly where they are,
coming off the Rocky Mountain
Front with bison.
Wolves are coming south
from Saskatchewan and out
from Yellowstone Park.
They're converging on that area.
This is huge, and the
elk are already there.
The wolf rumor mill is working,
and they're getting closer.
And they used to be here,
many, many thousands of them.
MALE SPEAKER: Having said that,
you can probably visit more
about this on your website.
How can they find
out more information?
SEAN GERRITY: Yes,
so I have cards here,
if you'd like to
go on our website.
I write a blog on
"National Geographic."
The best way to come
and get information
is come walk that
250 miles with us.
That's the best way, we
can talk day and night,
sit around the fire
with gin and tonics.
Glad to do that.
And truly, come and see it.
Many, many people
from California
come up to stay at Castro
Camp or wherever else.
And you'd be surprised
how many people
you might know, you start
talking, who have been there,
some of them numerous times.
And it's quite something.
It's a place you can go
back to over and over again
in different seasons and
see something different.
Whether you get to
see some coyotes,
the next time you come you
see the aurora borealis
or the northern lights from
your deck, sitting on your yurt,
because there are
no lights out there.
It is really quite something.
So coming to visit,
watching for information,
come to "National Geographic."
Because we do new things.
We just finished a science and
education center for instance.
Quite a lot activity this year.
But come take
information from me.
And particularly we are
very interested in working
with Google.
It's hard to-- I know what it's
like working in this valley.
If I sat here for three
months, I wouldn't know Google.
There are so many
things happening
in interesting pockets
of the company.
Please, reach out to me, and
we'll be back in a second
and come to you and talk about
it and see how it might work.
But we would love
Google's help for sure.
So any ideas, we're ready to go.
MALE SPEAKER: Well,
Sean, thank you very
much for speaking at Google.
SEAN GERRITY: Thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]